يدير ماكسيم هذا المطعم في كييف
لكن قلبه وفكره في المانيا
الى هناك لجات زوجته انيه وابنه ايفان قبل
اشهر
بعد 25 عاما من الزواج نعيش بعيدين
ونتواصل مع بعضنا عن بعد هذا ما فرضته
علينا الحرب نحاول السيطره على حياتنا
العائليه
هكذا فرقت الحرب ملايين الاوكرانيين ودمرت
بيوتهم كثيرون تحولوا الى لاجئين في اسقاع
العالم او نازحين في مراكز ايواء
لكن اخرين كانيكولاي قرروا البقاء وها هو
يحاول ترميم منزله بعد عشره اشهر على
تدميره
هذا المنزل كان سليما لكن سقطت عليه
قذيفتان تعالوا لاريكم هنا سقطت قذيفه
وهنا ايضا الان استبدلنا النوافذ هذه
نوافذ جديده وهنا العمال يقومون بما يلزم
نحاول ان نصلح بقدر الدعم الذي يقدم لنا
لكن الدعم مهما بلغ فلا يعيد الحياه هنا
الى ما كانت عليه قبل الحرب مشهد كهذا لم
يعد غريبا فلا مياها ولا كهرباء في
المنازل بعدما تضررت منشات الطاقه والبنى
التحتيه بالقصف الروسي
يصعب علي الانتظار من اجل تعبئه المياه
لاسيما عندما يكون هناك ازدحام كبير قبل
الحرب كانت المياه لا تنقطع في منازلنا
اما الان فلا
وخيمه الصمود هذه كما يسميها الاوكرانيون
تجد مثلها في مختلف ارجاء العاصمه
يقصدونها خلال ساعات التقنين بالتيار
الكهربائي فينعمون هنا بالدفء والطاقه
تقطع الكهرباء الان وفق مواعيد واحيانا
تقطع اربع ساعات متتاليه اتي الى هنا
لانني طالب جامعي وعلي متابعه المحاضرات
وانجاز فروض والان انا بانتظار ان يتمكن
الاستاذ من الاتصال بنا
هكذا تبدلت احوال الاوكرانيين بعد عام على
الحرب تبدل نرى جانبا منه في وجوههم لكن
اثره الاكبر يبقى في النفوس مع دخول الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا عامها الثاني لا
يلوح في الافق امل بنهايه قريبه لمعاناه
الاوكرانيين فالحرب لم تضع اوزارها بعد لا
بل تكون السلطات الاوكرانيه ان الاشهر
المقبله ستشهد هجمات روسيه اضافيه ما قد
يوسع نطاق المعارك ويطيل من امدها كاترين
حنا الجزيره كييف